[Musique]
donc le parrain ira très vite faisons ça
si vous voulez maintenant personne ne
l'a vu dans la salle donc personne vous
allez voir et là alors alors j'attends
ça commence bien
voici c'est le jeu dont celle qui
attaque le premier non je ne voudrais
pas répéter ce que j'ai déjà dit au
cours de salle de rédaction qui comme
vous le savez est diffusée tous les
dimanches non chez leurs amis j'ai pas
entendu ça à 1h30 les îles sur france
culture
mais je répèterai donc que le parent est
une grosse machine qui dure trois heures
avait beaucoup qui a remporté un succès
absolument fantastique puisqu'il a battu
tous les records de recettes depuis les
origines du cinéma et que lorsque nous
voyons ce film nous ne comprenons pas
car c'est un assez bon film bien ficelé
avec on peut se raccrocher que le
parrain pour déclarer est le chef d'une
dune des mafia sicilienne de new york
est à la tête de cette mafia il y à un
homme qui a des filleuls soit que ce
soit des hommes qui sont venus lui
demander sa protection
soit qu'ils les aient réellement tenus
sur les fonts baptismaux et ses hommes
sont sacrés il se dévoue pour eux il
fait tout pour eux mais ceux qui ne sont
pas ses filiales il les traite un peu
plus rudement et le nombre de morts qui
sont additionnés dans ce film doit se
monter à 20 ou 30 si ma mémoire est
exact car je signale que le film dure
trois heures et que évidemment on ne
veut pas additionner tous les cadavres
ont qui jalonnent ce film ceci dit il y
a deux numéros d'acteurs à mon sens
sensationnel le numéro de marlon brando
et surtout le numéro de al pacino qui à
mon sens est un numéro tout à fait
extraordinaire car le parent a voulu
que ses fils prenne sa relève quand cet
énorme affaire qu'il a monté avec le
concours de membres du gouvernement de
la police et de l'administration
américaine
car à l'amérique ça ne se passe pas du
tout comme en france quand il inventait
cet énorme affaire il a pensé qu'il
faudrait qu'elle qu'il y ait une suite
et il a songé à ses fils sauf aux plus
jeunes qui veut dont il veut faire un
honnête homme
quand il doit faire un gouverneur ou
peut-être même un sénateur
c'est pas qu'on veut faire et si oui
dans son décisions à notre encontre
gendre c'est un autre genre donc la rsa
clan ses genoux
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je crois
que dans son esprit il faudrait au
contraire qu'ils sont plus jeune fils
forte et nos méthodes or il se trouve
que par suite de la mort violente
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire de
tous ses frères ce jeune michael devient
le chef du gang
le chef de la mafia et devient à son
tour un parent puisqu'il tient sur les
fonts baptismaux le l'enfant de sa soeur
pendant que ses hommes demain massacre
littéralement tous les chefs des gang
adverse
voilà en 2000 mandat le livre revient
alors tout le monde n'a pas le livre
bien qu'il ait tiré à 300 mille
exemplaires à mon sens le livre n'est
pas très bon alors que les meilleurs que
l'oeuf est assez bon a seulement eu
assez bon mais beaucoup trop long mais
cette même un film qui va certainement
avoir un certain succès et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je crois qu'il
fallait dire en deux mots à ceux qui
nous écoutent que dans trois jours eut
pourront voir un film qui a battu tous
les records de recettes dans le monde
entier
nous verrons ce qui va se passer en
france bien merci chers au sol d'el
ayoun où on finira par savoir que celle
autant en emporte le vent du film de
gangsters on pourrait l'appeler
d'ailleurs autant non
le sens parce que je crois que le sang
coule quand même pas mal pour moi c'est
un film qui non seulement dure trois
heures mais représente énormément
d'argent je crois qu'on a voulu donner
beaucoup d'ampleur et beaucoup d'argent
un sujet qui était très éculés et
rabattu au finalement à l'espèce
d'incorruptible de luxe il n'y a pas
plus de contenus dans le film que dans
aucune émission de télévision des
incorruptibles
alors qu'on sait dans l'histoire du
cinéma il ya des histoires de mafia des
histoires de gangsters qui avait un
contenu freudien par exemple comme
scarface
janis krums jeunes y coule ecoterra
enfin le sujet n'est le sujet de très
nombreux prédécesseurs et ce film
n'apporte rien sinon une certaine
ampleur n'a vraiment joue elle joue
autant la porte avant en en donnant
énormément de l'épisode une foule
d'épisodes d'une foule de personnages et
et trois bonnes heures d'écran je crois
que ce que signifie plus que toute autre
chose le parrain c'est la renaissance du
vieil hollywood qu'on avait affirmé
spécialement quéribus cinéma avait
affirmé mort depuis dix ans environ
alors là c'est très nettement le retour
de toutes les vieilles ficelles doute
les vieilles recettes des beaux vieux
studio rafistolé finalement des
etats-unis à surmonter la crise qui a
été réelle gaieté eu vraiment une crise
des studios je conseille certains
studios ont été vendus et c'est alors là
on voit revenir des jeunes metteurs en
scène comme bogdanovic qui avait fait la
dernière séance houleux c'est pourquoi
oscar
enfin non pas aux carmes est l'un des
meilleurs films de l'année selon les
critiques américains puis french
connection qui a été lui un oscar et mon
avis aussi est très surfait et ce sont
des metteurs en scène qui ont une espèce
de nostalgie pour le cinéma des années
disons de leurs aînés et qui refont des
films à la roque sous à la ford mais mon
avis amdouni et oxford et je crois que
ces jeunes ces jeunes cinéastes
hollywoodiens ne sont pas les vrais
jeunes du cinéma américain via merci
robert brioude un road book jackrabbit
moridja comme un chouïa c'est de l'avis
de robert béné eu le retour aux vieilles
hollywood et surtout retour à la syntaxe
cinématographique car je ne sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais depuis quelques
années les films sont ce qu'on appelle
monter que monter katsav est d'ouvrir
qu' il n'y a plus aucune transition
entre les séquences entre les périodes
de temps ce qui a parfois des effets
tout à fait salutaire pour faire un
cinéma nerveux rapide et c'est ce qui a
quelquefois certains inconvénients de
compréhension et dans ce film là on
revient à au fond ce qui est là un peu
la ponctuation du langage
cinématographique comme les fondues les
fondus enchaînés ce qui ne se faisait
plus que jacob a tout à fait
c'est un film qui est qui est faite sans
aucune audace et justement en rajoutant
à peu près une demi heure de trop à
chaque séquence on ne fait plus du
cinéma de genre et pourtant sa faille
toujours sont des recettes qui sont
éprouvées et il faut pas qu aux
etats-unis en tout cas où le film a eu
un succès phénoménal
les gens aiment comprennent leur qu'on
prenne son temps comprennent leur temps
alors je suis content si j'ai parfois
aussi c'est à l'usagé il s'agit quand
même d'une super super progression
d'abord il ya il n'y a que des vedettes
tous les rôles de second plan sont joués
par des acteurs extrêmement connus ayant
faut dire que le film est extrêmement
bien joué et qu'il ya d'ailleurs
plusieurs séquences qui sont il faut
être objectif aussi il ya plusieurs
séances qui sont tout à fait saisissante
enfin le leur en manière de hollywood
qui ne veut pas se laisser intimider par
la mafia la tête de la tête de chou une
tête de cheval couper dans ses draps 10
soit au petit matin celle qu'il aime
quand on sonne assez prodigieuse il faut
démonter sentimentale qui vaut des
millions là seulement des scènes comme
ça il y en a il y en a 3 4 dans le film
et le film durait deux heures finalement
il serait bien assez bien borie qui n'a
rien dit hausse assez rapide pour moi
c'est pas de la crotte de bique c'est ce
que j'appelle de la bouche de mammouth
se situe énorme chose qui les trois
heures sous prétexte que les personnages
sont italiens avec ça saigne beaucoup
vous tapez 3 heures de sauce tomate
moi j'ai l'estomac fragile et ce genre
de cinéma je le supporte pas c'est tout
non mais écoutez c'est très exagéré
c'est très exagéré cette histoire de
sauce tomate parce qu'enfin on a défendu
à cette table des films je prends par
exemple les équipes oui le film de mon
passé pas basque il ya quelques
assassinats que le film est nul c'est
pas pour ça le grand snobisme maintenant
c'est de dire allez savoir ce film parce
qu'elle a du succès non ce serait un
film agréable à voir ne croyait pas que
je pars rappelé avoir du tout et marlon
brando je n'en déplaise à jean de
bordeaux et
dit que non pas du il promet la prog
nautisme de gargouilles désabusé pendant
trois heures nîmes immer dans des
plantes sauce tomate en jouant l'art
d'être grand-père si je dis que j'en
sors c'est didier cunin coach jean-louis
il est fâché il est fâcheux que tu sois
aps le dis parce qu'il est évident
qu'une âpre amis fous rires et
applaudissements
mais les jeunes n'y a pas de hordes car
peu de la santé marlon brando disparaît
au bout d'une heure mérité et le film
est fait uniquement de discuter de sa
succession du dorna quand il s'est
réveillé à 90 est arrivé coutume je
prends je prends benayoun et jacob on
croit qu'il est malhonnête ou alors la
mariée
christofias la raison en ce sens que
marmande on voit aussi dit ceci dit tu
as raison c'est pas par jour on a
beaucoup grossi par la performance
d'acteur de brando qui est relativement
facile c'est bourrel à la bouche avec
des morceaux de papier c'est bourré
l'abdomen avec des avec un petit plus un
et puis il joue à césar et disons-le il
fait un nouveau numéro de ringard au
fond c'est un grand acteur qui a fait
bien mieux dans sa carrière bon et vous
décevoir pas être exactement de
christian il valide a pas envie de
commenter ces propos paraissent
le parent ne l'inspirent absolument rien
[Musique]